choose the right number of each place  value to make 8,000 129 and we could say  this is 123 thousand so we could say it  is 1/10 2 hundredths and three  thousandths so let's just go place by  place so first we have 8 this 8 writers  in the thousands place it represents 8  thousand so we're gonna have 8 thousand  so let's select 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8  thousands then we have 100 so we  literally just have one 100 right over  there then we have 2 tens this 20 is 2  tenths we're gonna need two tens then  this 9 well that's just 9 1 so it's 1 2  3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and now we're going into  the tenths place this is only 1/10  so 1/10 right like that now this is 2  hundredths so we're gonna put 2  hundredths there then finally 3  thousandths  1 2 3 thousands and we check our answer  and we got it right